madame monsieur bonjour bienvenue dans
ce journal de 13h un journal que nous
démarrons tout de suite en nous rendant
en direct au val de grâce de nous
parviennent des nouvelles inquiétantes
concernant la santé de jean pierre
chevènement le ministre de l'intérieur
il y avait été admis mardi pour une
intervention chirurgicale prévue de
longue date mais il y a eu de graves
complications agnès vahramian vous êtes
sur place ans et non plus sur l'état de
santé de jean pierre chevènement
oui mais écoutez l'information donc nous
a été confirmé en fin de matinée par
l'hôtel matignon jean-pierre chevènement
est dans le coma sa situation est jugée
sérieuse
le ministre de l'intérieur donc vous
l'avez dit est rentré mardi matin pour
une intervention prévue de longue date
disait son cabinet une opération de la
vésicule biliaire qui a priori ne posait
absolument aucun souci
jean pierre chevènement avait d'ailleurs
prévu de reprendre tout à fait
normalement ses activités mardi prochain
après une courte période de repos mais
c'est hier soir donc au moment de
l'anesthésique que la complication est
intervenue jean pierre chevènement a
selon les termes médicaux aux officiels
fait un choc
anesthésiste c'est à dire une allergie
suivies d'un arrêt cardiaque
les médecins dans un premier temps ont
pu le réanimer le massage cardiaque la
durée d'ailleurs plus de 40 minutes
mais jean pierre chevènement est
finalement tombé dans le coma à l'heure
qu'il est l'avis des médecins est
d'ailleurs extrêmement réservés sur son
état de santé
et l'on doit attendre maintenant le
bulletin médical le premier bulletin
médical en fait des médecins du
val-de-grâce pour en savoir un peu plus
simple précision ce matin là la femme du
ministre de l'intérieur et son directeur
de cabinet ce sont sont venus ici au val
de grâce mais n'ont pas pu voir jean
pierre chevènement
merci à mios ici